It was my dream to be able to produce an adorable bobtail cat...
...that everyone would be able to enjoy.
April Arguin of Jacksonville, Florida...
...has successfully introduced two new cat breeds to the world:...
...the SphynxieBob and the BamBob.
The SphynxieBob looks identical to a regular Sphynx, has the gorgeous, big, round ears,...
...and the hairless features.
The only difference that makes them superior and unique is the short, little bobtail.
The unique feature of the BamBob is they're identical to the Bambino cat,...
...which is a hairless cat that carries the gene for short legs.
...so they have the same awesome look and short, cute little swagger...
...but they have a short bobtail.
You are the world's first ever!
It's definitely a passion.
It's not a business or something I do with the goal or intention to make money.
We do this for the betterment of the breed,...
...and really just the passion of sharing these amazing creatures with the world.